[Music]  this is the Oasis it's a place where the  limits of reality are your own  imagination  people come to the Oasis for all the  things they can do but they stay because  of all the things they can be  I'm here talking to all of you now  because our future is being threatened I  [Music]  just came here to escape but I found  something much bigger than myself  I found my friends  [Music]  now people have lost their lives this is  war  wrecking taller the kids of  [Music]  welcome to the rebellion wait  [Music]  you don't tell anyone who you are you  can't use your real name  this isn't just a game  and talking about to life-and-death  stuff  [Music]  are you willing to fight  [Music]  [Music]